[Music]
now some people say we were debating
this we think did we do that did we do
that little jingle before in an episode
and what I say is even if we did it
doesn't matter because guess what babe
you never step in the same river twice
because people do no but they do yeah
but they do but it's always flowing
water it's never the same river did you
change your shirt different water change
my shirt purple I didn't that's okay
you know what there it is now you're a
different because you're a new episode
now you're a different guy
I I um yeah I I heard uh I've been
listening ever I want to shout him out
Ryan Holiday from the daily stoic I
listen to his podcast every day so what
I want everyone at home to do is listen
to Ryan holiday's daily stalk podcast
and then listen to Hey babe or listen to
Hey babe person then Ryan Holliday's
podcast but it's every day it's only
about 8 to 15 minute episodes and it's
just advice from the stoics from Marcus
Aurelius epicteus um
these like ancient thinkers Seneca
ancient thinkers and when he said you
never step in the same river twice I was
like huh look at that how about them
apples you never do like today I I
walked the same way I always walked but
I walked in it with different energy and
even though it's the same blocks uh
seeing everything a little different
like even though you thought today you
got the same shirt on but you're not but
it's it's a different episode and you're
wearing the shirt a little different
this is a different episode please just
watch this one as well yes so
um yeah babe so I um
yeah I've been listening to that podcast
to daily they also have another email
blast called The Daily dad and I like
this I like getting a little dad advice
I think I know that great guy just he
wrote a book he sent it he sent it here
to the studio Shadow Brian it's not Ryan
holiday he's um he's got a muscular head
but a skinny body how do you have what's
a muscular head his head looks like he'd
be muscular but then his body's very
thin but how does your head play
musculars yeah it's got a good jaw but
then his body's thin
I like it a thin body thin body thin
body man people are shouting out sounds
flat feet why I don't know sometimes
people just do a photo of my five feet
babe you know by the way Summer movie
you know what I want to see you know
what I want to see
um Guardians of the Galaxy 3. I want to
take my kids to one of those movie
theaters where they um they bring like
when the one I told you I'm on Delilah
ordered five milkshakes oh okay where
they bring the food to you yeah can I
tell you something I lost don't tell me
I I don't no actually tell me I can
change my mind never saved her twice
I've lost about 120 pounds sure easily
you look great thank you you feel good I
got work to do well you look good you
noticeably you have noticeable weight
loss now I just want to let you well I
appreciate that we'll see what happens
I have fully fully fully disengaged and
do not care anymore about superhero
movies in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
whoa yeah I just can't I just can't keep
up and I and it's I I don't care enough
about the characters to invest in a
storyline that's in 30 different
directions to know all this
and I just don't even see that like the
Guardians of the Galaxy was a good movie
I remember laughing at it and I have no
desire to see yeah I can't I feel that
way about Spider-Man it's like there's
too many Spidermans I don't care about
the new Spider-Man I don't know who's
the Spider-Man anymore yeah I have no
clue what's going on I will say I I
identify with you with that when I see a
TV show
I'm not interested in starting a new TV
show I'd rather just watch a movie I
want to be done in an hour and a half to
two hours I need clothes I can't invest
time I haven't seen the last episode of
episode of succession yet have you yes I
have you saw it full to the end full to
the end okay so I haven't I fell asleep
I keep falling asleep because I can only
watch it during it yeah and I keep
falling asleep and I haven't watched the
end do you is it mind-blowing blow your
balls off ending or could they have done
a better job or tell me about it without
telling me telling me about it okay I as
a fan I was
I was
a little a little surprised
and satisfied by the ending you were
satisfied I don't think that they
the bet I think that there was a few
ways it could have went and they chose
one of the ways and they did it pretty
well okay so let me ask you a question
because I'm gonna try to finish it
tonight or tomorrow they did make a
choice they didn't leave it up there is
a clear-cut winner of this company there
is a there is a Clear Choice wow and it
ends kind of with that person and that's
it
it ends yeah it ends
yeah it's like wrapped it it's a you
don't have questions it's wrapped up but
it's like like it's it's it's it's not
but it is okay all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna watch it and let me tell
you something
there's some scenes in this one that are
I mean intense and wild like you
literally like even even if you've seen
all every single season and you've seen
scenes where you're like that was crazy
basically scene in this one where you're
like holy like you you any CX you
feel there was there's Zacks I don't
think this ever has been sex
y there has been sex any violence in
this one nobody gets killed or hurt in
any of these are shot
there was a little violence in the last
one when when Roman ran out into the
street oh yeah he got punched by the
protesters yeah yeah goddamn liberals
uh no there's a there's a scene in this
one well there's a really feel good
scene which is crazy because the
characters have no redeeming qualities
but that's very interesting they don't
but yeah we love them there's yeah
there's no there's no they're all
likable no redeeming qualities no you're
not rooting for anybody really it's
weird now they never give you enough if
you see a glimpse of a glimpse of
humanity in them they'd suck it right
back in me back up and there's no one
here that you're rooting for everyone
every person down to Greg is a terrible
person yeah it's kind of wild you know
Sopranos I didn't kicked that off and
then you had Breaking Bad and you had
like this like the it's the anti-hero
right and you know these are terrible
people but you gotta you got a
really nice you got you got something in
the last episode you didn't get in all
four seasons there's a scene that you've
never seen these characters like this
okay ever okay and then you also get a
scene that is so intense that I felt
physically uncomfortable right literally
like like my mouth was open like I I
felt my heart racing during the scene
and I felt uncomfortable wow that's good
that's a good scene it's a wild scene
all right I'm excited to watch it then
it's toward the end okay yeah it's an
hour and a half episode I can only watch
things at the end or we can only watch
shows at the end of the night but after
we put the kids to bed and me and Jess
get into bed we're usually just uh I'm I
fall asleep and jazz is up buying things
on Amazon you get through an episode and
that's it that's why if something's not
a little limited series now yeah limited
series Eight Episodes 10 Max 40 minutes
each can we ask you can I ask you what
do you talk about with your girl about
spending do you watch and monitor your
spending what do you guys talk about
because I have now over the last few
months of my life really paid close
attention to my spending and there's a
lot of times where I'm like we didn't
need to buy that much oatmeal yeah why
do you have why are you spending sixty
dollars a month on oatmeal yeah well
will the oatmeal eventually get eaten
yeah but there's no reason but but
stacks of oatmeal
I think these frivolous purchases than
than food yeah but I understand what you
mean and I'll tell you nothing and we
also don't need to keep getting out the
outdoor furniture we can live with the
outdoor furniture we have we don't need
to get an upgrade of an outdoor
furniture set uh we don't need to get a
new outdoor table because the last one
got you know ruined a little bit by the
weather yeah son it's dude I got my
table uh this is my fourth or fifth year
with it and I'm just I'm just Flanagan I
got it at no I got it that's the name
for my nuts Raymore and Flanagan your
celino and Barnes are mine are Raymore
and Flanigan do you like that I love it
all right good uh no we got us at West
Elm but um no dude honestly if you don't
pay attention to your spending and then
one day you do like a true a truly Deep
dive you'd be surprised right you should
always stay on top of your spending and
I I'm preach I'm I should follow my own
advice because I don't really you get
credit card bills sometimes you're like
I cannot sustain this credit card bill
pace
every month no no no no but this is
a lot of my
even though it's a lot is necessity like
it's you know it's you know we have to
plane tickets and hotels and and all
this stuff and you know and just the
regular bills and and that's that's the
the my minimum nut
is extremely high it's already high but
it's a business it gives me literal
anxiety yeah yeah but
um but no we don't we don't we're
careful with spending I spend money on
vacations on dining
that's it like things that are going to
create memories or make us like I don't
really spend on like watches or
anything exorbitant like I don't have
like like some crazy cards I just that's
what I spend money on so
but I have to spend money on top because
because being too Frugal is also giving
money too much power over you like
people think yeah oh overspending is a
problem but also underspending is a
problem too the little ways that I see
because I still I came I I was not I had
money growing up so you conquered I
can't answer again I had no money
growing up and like I I my
thoughts on money remain the same as
they always have which is what I I just
I'm very conservative with money right I
don't like to live above my means I
still think what the normal person
thinks is expensive is expensive just
because I have extra money it didn't
change the fact that I would be like
what they want like in the airport if a
sandwich is 15 I'm like what the
like this is crazy I'm getting robbed
but I guess where I do see some of the
impact because you also want to like you
work so hard you want to reap the
benefits of a better quality of life
right right so I guess flying first
class is where I see it right or like I
won't think about twice about taking an
Uber somewhere or something like that
like little things like that like where
in the past I would be like I can't take
an Uber every day this week right you
know though that's like kind of where I
let myself have it have it right now but
other than that no and I'll tell you um
my girl is like
she's even the same if not more like she
won't spend she'll she'll text me right
now she's like I'm at Target we need a
new blah blah blah this is 70 I don't
know if I should do it yeah and I'm just
like what are you talking about like you
just just get it it's 70 I mean like in
that respect but she's like that's how
much she is right yeah because I think
couples don't like I never really I
think it's very easy with our lives
being on autopilot everything automated
with apps and stuff like that to just
like not look at things or like and and
once you start to look you start to your
heart starts to sink where you're like
wait a second wait a second how many
times did we order out how many times
and then what I I spend money on that
and then what I've noticed though now is
what what's been happening because I
would say oh you know me and my family
we're home together but we're not
spending time together we're on our
devices we're letting kids watch TV even
if they're outside it's like I want to
spend time because what we've done now
what I just made a rule I said at least
three nights a week and it's it's been
more but I was like at least at the
minimum three nights a week all five of
us me Jazz and the three kids are going
to cook a meal together I love it each
one of us is going to get a job
obviously Jasmine is the only one who
knows how to cook so it's a lot of times
like even if my job is just to clean the
dishes and that's what I'll do but we're
all standing in the kitchen together no
devices doing it you know maybe we'll go
get a plate like we give the kids little
jobs and Jazz really does most
of it but we're all like in together and
that's that's the moment you're gonna
remember and then and then it's like and
it's and it's like literally so much
better life quality but so much cheaper
too financially like when we're order I
mean you know if we ordered like we got
you know chicken we made um like chicken
parmesan and spaghetti the other day and
it's like you know we bought two packs
of chicken cutlets one all eight for
three two boxes of spaghetti some grated
cheese and a salad and it costs like
forty dollars one chicken parmesan from
the place we like to get to was 38 yeah
so I would have spent close to which I
would do yeah just oh because it's easy
I would say just if I man oh you know
what let's order the food because then
actually we're going to spend more time
together because we don't have to worry
about cooking as opposed to just saying
but it's the opposite of strong is the
journey that's it baby yeah no I love
rules and traditions I'm all for it yeah
me too I'm gonna be a sit down at the
dinner table guy together like when when
I you know when when I have kids and
they're older and all that stuff it's
difficult now for me like with my with
the especially having eight-year-old and
a 12 year old they when you tell them to
get off their devices you just have to
deal with a pro like you just have to
deal with like them freaking the
out yeah but I'm just willing to deal
with it and I'm starting to try to take
their devices away this is another thing
that daily stoic said is uh behavior is
the language of children which is really
true and I started to implement this a
little bit when my daughter like the
other day my daughter was like just in a
freaking mood yeah like I could like
screaming doesn't want to go to trash
she doesn't know what she needs but it's
coming out right yeah because the
two-year-old it's like I understand and
my two-year-old you know she's a baby
but my eight-year-old I was like what
she can communicate but then I was like
when I heard Behavior as a language of
children I was like wait a second she's
only eight she actually can articulate
that so I guess communicating yeah with
her behavior so I just sat her down and
I went through just what her basic needs
are and if they're being met I said you
have to go to the bathroom no do you
feel hot no do you feel cold no are you
hungry yes so she didn't know how to
tell me even though she's very smart and
articulate whatever she didn't know to
be like Daddy can you just please make
me a sandwich and then I'll calm down
and had to ask her because her behavior
was telling me something is wrong right
so I was like I'm fine I just made her I
made her she wanted a banana sandwich I
was like okay I'll make you just banana
on bread banana bread I was like it's
actually interesting I took apart I was
like not bad banana banana on bread and
she loved it and then 20 minutes later
because she was satiated her behavior
changed and we had a great day yeah so I
was like oh Behave behavior is the
language of children that was a big
thing the daily dad said that I liked
yeah you know you're you are a modern
day homo
homo homo homo sapien almost there yeah
no you are you're a modern day uh uh uh
philosopher you you really uh well I'm
just regurgitating what Ryan Holliday
said but you read every week you have
read someone else every year well read
and you and you you retain
and apply write it down you retain and
you apply because I write it down I make
sure like there's certain things that
like I just look at I just look at every
day and I just read you want to hear
yeah do you know that I can't read and I
can't retain really yeah because
D is that a fever pitch I just upped the
dose I I'm just trying so hard and I
hate taking prescription drugs I hate it
but I'm on my second different
prescription drug on the fourth
different dose level and I did the first
drug I did three dose levels right and
like I'm just trying to find something
that will work for me because it's like
a mental prison it might be maybe try no
drugs see what happens I only tried I've
only tried getting on these prescription
meds for the last like three not even
three months three months so probably
give it another three months and then I
never took in what happens you know yeah
here's the here's the things here's the
things and again more daily stomach but
here's the four things that I look at
every day I look at these things every
day we and Seneca said these we suffer
more in imagination and then in reality
it's a big one associate only with
people who improve you that's a hard one
to do but something I've been trying to
implement huge the greatest remedy for
anger is delay
so just when you're mad and you're
emotional that's what I've been putting
into practice just delay just delaying
typically goes away and uh death uh
value your time more than your
possessions that's a big one time more
than possessions and then the last time
death is not in the distant future we
are dying every day that's a that's
that's that's a big one so that those
things I apply I don't know if I like
that last one but it's but it's but it's
the truth
part of my uh death is not in a distant
future we are dying every day yeah well
the ADHD it also exacerbates or helps uh
bring on the anxiety and depression so
and I have a as we talked before I'm a
guy that has big problems with like
death and stuff like that but why but
you have to figure out why because I
think that I'm trying dude I'm going to
therapy like I'm just trying but I I
can't I gotta so not to get too serious
ornament but but anyway that's what the
podcast is so he's like so he's like why
is he just like is he just like um is it
he's just like does that mean Carpe Diem
to him is that what that means what is
when he says not as if you were dying
every day is it like what do you take
away from that because I could take away
a couple of things yeah depth is not in
the distant future we are dying every
day what I take from that is to
again just different ways to say things
that we know being in the present living
in the now not putting off tomorrow what
I could do today what Benjamin Franklin
would always say you know if you can do
it now do it now be in the now because
your death nobody knows when it is so it
can to sit and think that you have all
the time is no I don't think that I
actually feel like a ticking clock
actually so then why so if you feel like
a ticking clock then I would then go
back to the third one value your value
your time more than your possessions so
then you deal with your time and then
who's in your life friends family
whatever and you spend more time with
them or get the balance get the balance
did we talk about this ever before I I
was saying how like I maybe it was you
were the Rosa maybe we wasn't on a
podcast but how like when we were little
time was so slow right it was on a
vacation felt like an eternity yeah so
eighth grade or sixth grade felt like
that's ten years that's what I want to
do I almost want to try to just be like
do absolutely nothing like below block
out nothing right and then just like
like I was a kid in eighth grade or a
retired person because those are the
days that like you get up you walk
outside at 8 A.M you come back in at 6
p.m that day feels like a year right I
wanted to slow down everything well I
think then but that's but that's
probably like you know maybe meditating
more being in one place more when we're
on the go all the time which is the
nature of our career yeah it tends to
make things go so fast another what
happened
here we go pimp just pulled up the size
and complexity of the networks of
neurons in our brains increases as we
age electrical signals must Traverse
greater distances and thus signal
processing takes more time so actually
time does slow down as you get older
right is that goes faster I'm sorry yeah
yeah because of a neurological thing
it's real yeah Traverse greater
distances and thus signal processing
takes more time I don't get well how's
that saying the time goes slower because
it takes more time to think the commute
across your brain gets longer
sure but we're talking nanoseconds
though or like are they just you know
like it's not something we can feel well
we just said we could feel it that's
time feels fast I just felt like because
we are there's so much coming at us in
every direction so much more
responsibility so much more
communication information that it just
feels like you know we're we're we're
going from one thing to the next
throughout the day like we're just
punching a clock
well like it's like that story ARA
shaffir just told me this yesterday
um like the story of the fishermen when
he's if you know guy wealthy Guy Fisher
he's a fisherman and then somebody's
like well why don't you get why don't
you get
um why don't you go go get uh another
fishing boat and he's like okay and then
what and they're like well you know you
catch more fish he's like yeah and then
what and he's like well then you'd be
able to get more fish and buy even more
fishing boats he's like okay yeah and
then what he's like well you'd catch
more fish with the fishing boats and
your Empire would grow it's a rat race
even bigger and he goes yeah and then he
goes well and then you could retire he
goes and what would I do when I retired
and the guy who was saying and then what
was like I'd be fishing so he's like so
I'd I'm doing what I'm already wanting
to do now not this endless Chase of
money because people will just chase
money and money and money until they die
and then they're like at the deathbed
you know I've talked about this I think
on hey babe or Chrissy chaos the book I
read the five reasons five things you
must know before you die about this
author John Izzo just interviewed 20 or
30 people on their Deathbed all said the
same thing none of them valued their
possessions they only missed the time
that they that they missed out with
their family so it's like at what point
you have to like have a number whatever
that number is it's like this is enough
money I need to live and that's what
I'll deal with because it's like that's
why I don't do two shows in a night
anymore very rarely do I do two shows at
nights I'm like I don't I don't want the
pressure or stress I know it's more
money but I'm losing time so that that's
what but that's why that that I think
that daily stomach thing would be good
for you because you listen to it every
day it's like a meditation and I
personally even though there's very very
smart motivational speakers and all that
that are living today I that's fine but
I just trust advice that's two thousand
years old that has a bigger impact on it
because I'm like if they're saying we're
saying that 2 000 years ago like look at
this one these are you saying I should
just start fishing starfishing
there's here's let's say I blame rappers
blame rappers I do yeah we're putting so
much value on material possessions
here's the thing too and he was coming
up and all I thought it was I need to
get like you know I need to be rolling
on dubs dude even even podcasting I was
I read these two the other day and I was
like oh great well there's three of them
I I read these things these are from
Marcus Aurelius and Zeno Xeno was like
the Xeno was like the David Texas
Warrior Xeno was a princess warrior but
Xeno was like the stoic stoic like it's
this once the stoics looked up to like
how David tells like the Comics comic so
and I feel like literally this is what
we do this is our career now is what we
do each week is on podcasting is exactly
these strings he said do not who's
the guy this is Marcus Aurelius and Xena
Xeno is the same does he know walk
around in a black Carhartt hoodie with a
iced coffee yes okay yes he does okay so
he says don't be overheard complaining
even to yourself which is what we do
every week is just sit on here and
complain don't put on heirs about your
self-improvement what Ayers means is to
act in a way that shows one thinks is
better than people so don't put on
errors about yourself Improvement all I
do is hear Come on talk about my
fasting
don't speak more than you listen
one mouth two ears all we do on here is
speak speak speak
and don't listen and the last one is
don't over indulge in eating or drinking
that's from masonius so I was like it
was just a very revealing thing to me
where I was like the last guy was like
dude yeah don't be a fat yeah yeah
it's like uh let me tell you something
it'll change your life yeah the last guy
was like I agree with Chrissy you should
intermittent fast but I was like it was
just this ancient wisdom I was like hmm
I'm in a career now where I'm doing
three of the things they said don't to
do so obviously keep the career but how
can I just be better at it and be more
mindful of it I don't know the answer at
all I have zero clue that's the
thing with me it's like I can I can tell
I can read all these things and ingest
them and write them down but then I do
not know how to put into practice and
that is what life is about is the
execution and I don't know how to do it
yeah but it's on the brain it's on your
mind it's insane and you you consume so
much and retain so much that I think
it's it will process and it will be it's
starting to build a fabric of in your
subconscious I do think that the more
that you read this stuff and under and
consume and understand it that it's
going to shape your decisions without
you even knowing better habits I stopped
the negative self-talk I used to even as
a joke like in the morning I would be
like you suck Chris I stopped all
because yeah because also because you
thought I'd be self-deprecating and like
the the habits make the man as that
picture said all right so let's say
money goes out of existence like it's
totally out the window out the window
what do people do what do people with no
money I think that I think that with
with no money then you probably society
would I think like there would probably
inevitably war and violence and all that
because people would get that out but
then I think you'd get to a time where
you'd probably be a more peaceful place
and the power is the root of all evil
right so if you don't have money you
don't have how do you get power without
money
and then how would you sell people their
own addictions
right yeah because there's no currency
would you be would you be able to go
back to a bartering system like when
Jesus flipped the tables yeah you know
what I mean what would you bother what
would be the first thing you bought I
mean what's your most prized possession
like like material possession material
possession prized all right like what
would be the highest value like I ain't
giving this up
um it's probably stuff that's invaluable
you know like not something that's like
like you know oh my something like
what's something you would barter to get
the to so that they somebody wouldn't
kill your family like we're out there
you have this thing are you asking me
I'm saying we're in an apocalyptic world
yeah we're back to the bartering system
okay money's lost its value but you're
gonna kill your family unless you give
me what okay but let me ask you a
question do you mean that what do I have
that I think will be most valuable in
someone else's eyes for the barter or
you just this way of you asking me what
are some things that I have that are
invaluable to me or like is this like is
strategic like what do you what do you
mean I'm saying like you don't you asked
me what my most expensive thing is are
you asked me what I think has the most
value to somebody else or do you say me
what what to me is so invaluable that I
you know like I'm saying you actually
don't even know what the person who has
a gun to your family's head is even
thinking he's just saying give me your
most prized possession and I'll give you
and I'll take
necessarily be money yeah well the thing
the things I or my prioritizens have no
value to anyone else you know it's like
uh I mean it's pictures of my family
that'd be funny you give pictures that
your family just blows everybody's heads
off he's like what the is this
trips to Disney World
you're like I'm like a flock of sheep
about this pic of being kindergarten
yeah yeah no um I I don't know like
silly stuff like things that I'm like oh
my God I can't believe like I have uh
Don Rickles uh autograph I love
personalized autograph to me framed on
the living room yeah like I you know
that represents a moment that I met him
and I really looked up to him he reminds
me of my grandfather he like I don't
know I just I just like uh he's a legend
he's an icon right and I I got to talk
to him he gave me advice he was very
humble and sweet he gave me his time
with me and my dad and my lady and uh it
was just one of the most special moments
and and I he signed it and what he wrote
was so cool I mean he didn't know that
he didn't know that I was already like
having some good fortune in this
business right but he just like we
talked about it because he just told him
I was a comedian gave me and he just
wrote uh Sal I know I know that you'll
make it right I love you and I was just
like I don't know that sets us up man
like if there's a fire I was like I
gotta run and get that that's what you
would get in the fire yeah okay I mean
that's not my most I'm just what comes
to mind you would bought that physical
possession that means a lot to me it
doesn't mean something to anyone else
you know right it would be it would work
out if the guy uh who's who's had the
gun in your family's head was a Rickles
fan it wasn't a Rickles fan well then I
could just give him a pair of like
Jordan Chicago's from like
1995 or something I don't know would you
do you think by the way do you think I
know this is ADHD a little bit do you
think that LeBron James is a better
basketball player than Michael Jordan do
you think that because it's it's come to
that debate now do you think he's number
one what do the stat lines say LeBron is
way better stats way better he's the
all-time leading scorer but way better
yeah and Rings uh Jordan has six I think
LeBron does LeBron have four
how many did he win he won one with the
Lakers how many championships does
LeBron James have let's look at this
right here Ben okay when Jordan retired
at what age the Gap in total numbers
were won and doesn't appear to be
slowing down 38. well how many years
have they been is it years to years
years I want apples to apples here
I love when you say Apples to Apples
it's a cool fun thing so Jordan while
LeBron's played in 400 more games so he
has 6 000 more points
but he has 4 000 more rebounds
he has twice as many assists
more games
wow a lot more rebounds a lot more
assists and I don't think the ratio is
such that those 400 games isn't
necessarily what's doing it because like
with a CIS he has double right so that
means I think though there's something
magical about Michael Jordan maybe it
was because of his brand that it's like
LeBron is arguably the the greatest
player of all time but it just doesn't
feel like is that turnovers like he gave
up he yeah he turned the ball over twice
as much as LeBron wow no no no LeBron
did LeBron I'm sorry yes LeBron is also
Michael Jordan's Space Jam was better
than LeBron's it was and Gatorade and
Gatorade is just like Michael Jordan
made Gatorade he made Nike like like
what did LeBron it's pretty good I
didn't see the area it's pretty good
every Gatorade and glass bottles I wish
they would bring back glass Gatorade
bottles yes why did they get rid of
glass bottles I say this every time we
record and every time I promise you I
promise you it's true I use doordash
last night you did it again yeah dude oh
two nights ago two nights ago door Dash
It's amazing we were watching the I
think you should leave a season I love
it right it runs 90 minutes right
through it's not a whole bunch of people
over use doordash to order a white pie a
grandpa pie and 12 wings yummy yummy in
my tummy yes and doordash now they have
a dash pass membership which you can
save on all your grocery and restaurant
favorites with a zero dollar delivery
fee on all eligible orders you just sign
up for that dash pass membership and
it's just door Dash It's you know they
got thousands of grocery stores to
choose from they work with all the major
chains I love it you can get 50 off your
doordash order up to a ten dollar value
when you use the code
babe2023 at checkout limited time offer
term Supply but that's 50 off up to a
ten dollar on a 15 minimum subtotal and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code
babe2023 don't forget that's code babe
2023 for 50 off your first order with
doordash that's right mm-hmm Double D's
I love this Viator is the oh I know what
I've been telling you about Viator every
time I travel yes the first thing I do
after I book my flight hotel is I go to
Viator and I see what tours they have
available via tour is one of my favorite
apps that I have on my phone because I
literally I have been using Viator for
at least 10 years I I just that I only
get tourists Revival and I go on the
best tours I've only just heard about it
when they signed on with us and I and I
looked it up and I'm like how is
everyone not using this it's the best
and I began to use it because they gave
us a little promo code yeah and I'm
already uh I'm your boy is going to be
taking a helicopter pretty soon really
yeah absolutely there you go so yeah uh
right they have over 300 000 bookable
travel experiences and over a hundred
and ninety countries they offer
everything from simple tours to Extreme
Adventures all the niche stuff in
between I I'm telling you I can't
recommend this app enough yeah it's like
it's like your own personal travel agent
if you land in a new place and you're
visiting you're traveling you're like
what can we do here what's interesting
here you go on this app and it should be
your first stop if they call you to to
confirm the night before they tell you
exactly where to be Viator again I can't
recommend it enough download the Viator
app right now and use code Viator 10 for
10 off your first booking one app over
300 000 experiences you'll remember do
more with Viator that's v i a t o r the
code is
v-i-a-t-o-r-10 for 10 off your first
booking babe guess what tomorrow my fall
tour goes on sale we've added so many
cities just go to chrisdcomedy.com for
tikiwickies a lot of them are almost
sold out so go find your city and if
your City's not on there you know
Instagram me Twitter me yell at me tell
me I need to go to your city but tell
all your friends to come to the shows
with you in the city that you live in
okay christycomedy.com for tikiwickies
what's up guys first things first the
Impractical Jokers cruise is happening
January 22nd to the 26 2024 we are
hosting it with Eric Andre uh there's
gonna be a ton of comics and bands and
DJs it's our fifth one you can get
tickets right now it's 65 sold out uh at
pre-sale so get tickets right now at get
ship faced cruise.com you could also
enter to win a free trip and practical
jokers are finishing out the first leg
of our tour now through July all uh
dates and tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com in the coming
weeks we have Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City Nashville uh St Louis and am
I forgetting anything
that's it
do you think Gatorade will bring back
the glass bottles maybe if they're
watching and we know that they are is it
too much costly you think it's cost too
much you know what I think you do I
think you leave here today you get in
your car
I think you navigate uh you put in GPS
to get to Staten Island when you go back
to Staten Island I think you make a
right off the first exit and you go
about a half a mile you park and you
take it up with Bloom Cafe that's it
that's what I think you do taking up a
Bloom Cafe by the way they just aren't
they they uh have some new menu items
there that are delish really they got
them they're vegan uh gluten-free
cupcakes or um Devil Dogs I should say
are amazing yeah I eat them all day
well only on Saturdays
yeah my kids eat them yeah look at that
wow 1960 that's funny the 19th where's
the glass bottle
are you taking a Snapple bro
yeah but you didn't we didn't drink that
in 67. wait a second is my am I am I
getting um
were they what do they call um like
Sinbad um what's that called oh like the
butterfly butterfly effect when I'm a
mat I'm I'm remembering something like a
glass gatorade bottle that never existed
yeah because that the 89 one was really
what I remember and that's really the
same one 1996 I kind of remember with
the nipple
the 97 one kind of is what it's been the
plastic one yeah which is also yeah
they've been they've they've held the I
mean remember when Gator remember
Gatorade gum no yeah they had gum I want
to get a gatorade T-shirt with the old
symbol just says Gatorade I bet you
could pick that up at Target you think
so we do a lot of branding now with that
right yeah right uh I think Jordan
Gator government was called what do you
what do you what do you value more in
the end when you're looking at a career
stat lines or rings I mean you could you
could have been a guy that's lucky I
mean at the right on the right teams at
the right time and had x amount of rings
right but no stats to say that your
greatness I say stats because for me
it's like but isn't that like the
Nuggets like the Denver Nuggets right
now are in the NBA just finals and it's
like they were they've been a finals
level team for years but you have the
Golden State Warriors who were arguably
one of the best franchises in the last
20 years playing in the NBA so it's like
there's always a franchise to get
through Clyde Drex from the Portland
Trailblazers could have won the NBA
Finals but then when Jordan was playing
yeah same thing with the freaking Knicks
yeah so so it's it's it's tough I think
that
and that could be a little out of touch
because I'm not as into basketball
as I was when I was younger but I think
Jordan has a much bigger cultural stamp
wow LeBron's been in the finals 10 times
wow yeah so he has but Jordan never lost
he has four more final appearances than
Jordan Jordan Jordan has won every
single every time he went to the finals
he won that's something though something
yeah
I don't know um because yeah once you
win if you win three of them it's like
could be a flu but when you win six
every you went to the NBA finals six
different times and you won six
different times with different savings
that says like because he has four how
many does LeBron have LeBron has four in
ten yeah and Jordan has six so you're
talking about um you know a four uh if a
forty percent turnover a forty percent
win ratio in the finals versus a hundred
percent yeah that's different
and he's played 400 more games and I
almost had the same amount of playoffs
appearances who is the greatest white
man of all time
not an athlete
who do you think is the number one white
man let's go with let's do the number
one white man the number one black man
the number one Asian man and the number
one woman okay
the woman is overall encompasses all
over all Races the parameters for
greatness for me I think greatness would
be
um changed culture uh in a positive way
uh did did positive uh things for uh
themselves
um
I think that um uh also greatness like
they a culture are you talking about a
cultural icon or like what are you
talking about you know what I don't know
if there will be talking about
you have to make your own parameters who
is the greatest let's start with the
white who is the greatest white man of
all time you go then I'll go and we'll
go race by race oh Jesus is it a
president it could be it's up to you to
decide the premise because as I tried to
sound it out I was like that's already
taking I'm already now shrinking it I'm
all right you got people in your head
already no that's a massive question I
like I have to be my enrolled and I
don't even know I have the Asian in my
head you have the Asian I have the Asian
is it is it it's not like is Tiger Wood
what's he considered
and not that he is but I'm just saying
like he's successful sure but like I
would say
who's who's he drafted here I'm gonna
say if they're mixed race if they're
mixed race it's who they look more like
from the back so I'm gonna say Tiger
Woods facing the wall looks more black
than Asia okay are you gonna hit me with
like a Confucius no okay are you gonna
you're gonna hit me with a philosopher
for sure you never know you're gonna hit
me with uh
an eight who's the who's the biggest
Asian contributor to do you have the
white man yeah oh you want to start with
the Asia I don't know I'm just I'm
trying to think of anybody to tell you
the truth it's a it's a very lofty
question okay
are you gonna go like
I'm very interested where you're gonna
go because you're the guy that loves a
good 2000 year old right you know they
don't have to be you go to Socrates but
you also love a mosque right you know
right I feel that you do yeah yeah 100
there's a mosque you know on Myrtle
Avenue where I used to grow up big
monster right used to be next to the
Dolphin Fitness club where I used to
work out oh yeah yeah but you which side
are you on with Musk with Elon Musk
I think he's not contributing more good
than bad or more bad Oh I thought you
meant are you counting me as white or or
African oh oh no because he's South
Africa South Africa yeah i i i s I would
say musk I don't have a problem with
Elon Musk but he's not he's not the
greatest white man okay to me
it's a tough one
if you have someone
I'd love it to inform
my thought process okay so for the for
me the first one
out of the gate I think the greatest
white man to me is George Washington
okay I think I put him at number one
Founding Father did great yeah but he
also if you look at his old Twitter not
good yeah oh no what there's debate the
thing is there's debate there's debate
on all of them yeah because that's why
it's I immediate immediately went back
to older presidents but I'm like hey
it's dicey dicey dicey as a
okay maybe that's what I heard the king
and did I see dicey someone said dicey
oh no gang gang gang gang people have
tags the greatest Asian man to me is
Bruce Lee
I'll put him as top age okay so I I
thought of Bruce Lee yeah but then I was
like what about all the unbelievable
Asian it's philosophers and it's Up For
Debate but I'm saying it's how do you
feel do you think Bruce Lee is uh
genuinely because not only was he uh the
the ultimate at his craft and a cultural
he was a call has cultural significance
but do you think that
his representation of Asian culture was
something that
affected like the world like yeah I mean
like when you when you have when you get
you know when you cross over or when
something is get made accessible to you
and you you learn something instead of
being ignorant about it because a lot of
times when people are ignorant about
something right they they fear it
because they don't know it well yeah I
think because Bruce Lee is somebody
who's his he transcended culture I mean
there's no Wu-Tang without Bruce Lee
right right there's not
I mean Bruce Lee was the one who brought
all I think well it was well I guess if
you're saying if he was the
the biggest name in all of Asian the
Asian those Asian you know films and
everything Bruce Lee claimed he could he
could kill you with a punch an inch away
from your chest yeah
I don't believe it so he's a so but he's
your greatest my greatest Asian but
listen many men and women you know we
all have flaws
wait what is this pimpy
the most searched people on Wikipedia
Carl linnius who the hell is that
there's all white males apparently wait
I know everyone on this except for
carlinia is the number one guy who is
that
why is he the honest is the number one
researched person how is that even
though that list
yeah it doesn't make any sense
a Swedish bondage zoologist taxonomist
and physician I mean pick a career and
go with it I mean the father of modern
taxonomy what is taxonomy taxonomy is um
uh Taxidermy is it yes stuffing dead
animals which is weird would you ever
consider when you die instead of getting
buried or cremated would you be
taxidermied it's not right it's not
taxes
would you would you be taxidermy I don't
know because if you can't capture the
soul behind the eyes I think it would be
everything would be unsung do you think
have there been humans who have who have
opted to be taxidermied what
you want the soul captured
yeah well like you know I don't want to
look into dead open eyes you know what I
mean like I want to see the life behind
it I want to see the essence of life in
there like a painting then yeah yeah
like so I don't know unless they figure
unless the taxidermists figure out how
to like make the eyes look like I'm
still sitting here right people get you
ever see there was a show I think it I
think
there was a show and I'm pretty sure it
existed uh it was called like the
world's craziest or best funerals oh
really did you ever see this like my
Superstar
Taxidermy people oh they did yeah they
got a guy I'm not even kidding they got
a guy at his funeral in full Street
where holding like a 40 wearing like a
crown yeah yeah yeah yeah that one I've
seen look at this guy they're all
dressed up as milk and eggs
Lord we want to thank you for the food
breakfast of Clinton
oh my God oh my God
why will it two bacon strips behind him
[Laughter]
he has to come on the pod
why are the guys behind him so so they
look like they look like Secret Service
bacons
this can't be real is this a bit or this
is real
oh it's fake
oh no but it's real but he really died
this kid and they decided to do this
his grandma is dressed as an omelette
this is crazy this guy we're breaking
eggs over his casket
s
oh my god you're kidding me
you know what I would do you want me to
get these people for your funeral if you
die before me do you want me to would
you prefer if I did this for you yes
okay is that are you being dead because
I'll remember this if no God willing we
live another 40 50 years I'll do this
for you no I want this all right so we
heard it we have this is what you want
okay great I mean yeah I mean this is
crazy I mean he he's like he told us we
don't have to have breakfast in the
morning he's like that wasn't him yeah
he was so far before I mean why is he
wearing a shower cap I don't oh this
podcast as always sponsored by better
help babe better help babe I mean you
know if you've benefited from therapy
before which we have yeah and we suggest
better help we both use it yeah right it
helps us we're just talking about
therapy before the cameras even came out
you find more balance with better help
it's done entirely online from the
comfort of your own home you don't have
to go anywhere to a brick and Morty you
don't do any of that it's private they
you take a little survey they match you
up with the therapist that fits best for
you if you don't like that therapist
then you can change it at any time and
we'll give you a great discount all you
got to do is go to betterhelp that's
help
betterhelp.com hey babe get 10 off your
first month that's betterhelp.com hey
babe 10 off your first month
excellent listen let me tell you about
the game time app okay like today I'm
going to the Yankees Mets game I used
game time to get the best seats for the
best price if you wanna and doesn't
that's not only sporting events whatever
event you want to go to buying tickets
to your favorite events should not be
stressful and Game Time takes away all
distress they get Flash Deals last
minute tickets easy to find and buy
tickets for every kind of event in your
area you don't have to plan months in
advance you know why because game time
has deals on tickets right up to the day
of the event the game time guarantee
listen to this it means you're always
going to get the best price and if you
find tickets in the same section or Row
for Less game time is going to credit
you 110 of the difference listen to that
tickets in the same section and row four
less game time gives you a hundred and
ten percent of the difference the only
choice is Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use the
code hey babe for 20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem code hey babe for 20
off download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed I've
never put a shower cap on in my life I
don't think I ever have
you mean for function for real or just
trying it on I don't think you've never
been in a hotel busted went out and just
walked around the room in a shower cap
no and you know what I've you know what
I'm prepared to tell you and I can't
prove it but I do think it's a fact I
think in my life in the course of my 38
years of life I've worn a hat on my head
less than 20 times I think I'm 20 times
or less with a hat on Wow let me think
about this
you don't wear baseball caps nope you
really don't not even backwards throw
away yamakas you don't do fedoras nope
you don't do sun visor I don't want
cowboy hats you don't wear shower caps
nope you don't wear beanies I don't wear
sombreros every time I wear a beanie you
make a comment like you can pull that
off uh yeah but but but I really feel
like you're saying like
I don't like you in the beanie but I
have to comment on it right yeah you
don't wear silly no I love you you don't
wear silly hats like dumbbells like
those big hats that the women wear no
very you know wear bonnets I think it's
less than 20 times in my life maybe I'll
call 30 times why do you think that is
do you think that you have a face for
hats I don't I think I I don't have a
good hat head I think my head's too big
and I think I have a big forehead all
right
yeah what you literally you literally
look like a little Leaguer right now the
way you put that out but put it on like
the way you would wear it okay like put
it on as if you were gonna walk in here
and I do I think twice no way no way no
way it looks insane on you yeah because
we're not used to it right if if you
wore it all the time but it looks so
jarring yeah yeah I don't I don't like
it let's see how it looks on Yolanda
I mean she pulls anything off we know
that she pulls it off I yeah I don't
know I'm not uh I'm not a hat guy you
ever call 9-1-1
no I've never realized you've never
called 911 in my life
why'd you call 9-1-1 I have in my life
many I'd say in my life I probably call
9-1-1 at least five times because you
were having an emergency or you were
witnessing an emergency
um did I ever call for my own emergency
like I was with a friend one time that
needed it and then I called but most of
the time I'm calling because I witnessed
something I believe you know what's the
late what's the last time you call now I
know I know um we call well I didn't
call but the guy in the car we called
two weeks ago when I shot a gun at us oh
that's right yeah
what did they say like there's nothing
we can really do no they just were like
well for them they asked like where
where we could find like they asked
specifics but 911 well the Nuggets just
got to the finals so yeah people are
shooting it's going to be yeah it's the
first time they ever made it hello yeah
they're like call 3-1-1 we don't want to
call three on one yes three on one I've
called for what what about when we just
have to call 4-1-1 to get information
about anything
holy I haven't thought of 4-1-1
yeah since the last time I dialed 4-1-1
dude that was the first like that was
that was Google
tell me right now there's a person
walking around right now that's like I
support my family I'm a full-on-one
operator
hold on
um Brooklyn New York that's right
and then they connect you with a local
411 person
um say resonance residence s for a
well-known celebrity that lives in
Brooklyn
essential listing you can save residents
is it all automated
right
residents
and Hathaway residents say just the
person's last name Hathaway
right yes
for Hathaway top two results to select a
listing say it's number number one Aid
Hathaway on 355 Pacific Street
uh number one
a Hathaway
are we maybe gonna have Stephen Hathaway
like if everything goes right does she
live
parade because I feel like we'll fall in
love and everything
hi
um Anne
Hathaway
press one to have a text message
um
yeah I'm uh
uh I'm being connected to Anne Hathaway
yes it is
what's the
being connected to Anne Hathaway
she Is Beautiful Jesus Christ this is
but this is 10 years ago yeah but hello
and I'm not Anne
they hung up on me wait wait so so
there's no wait I have to a live person
just now hold on hold on is it all AI
look I just got they just sent me
Hathaway A the number the and the
address I'm calling this number I'm
calling this number and see if it's
gonna happen what's the address
you should probably beep that out okay
when we put it on
when Wireless Your call cannot be
completed dude that is a good that's a
that's a nice block that's a nice block
full of Brownstones I have to piss like
you can imagine I also have to piss like
it wow you know holy you never have
to piss
I drank coffee maybe I don't know what
it was I've been drinking a lot of iced
coffee you know I don't have to piss I
have a light sensation I I I I don't
normally piss until I have a a medium to
heavy sensation by the way I forgot to
tell you today this morning I I
was in the city pretty early and I was
walking to
the boxing place and a car was turning
off uh Bowery Street a car was turning
and a guy on a city bike wearing a full
suit and a helmet on a city bike like
you know kind of like had to weave in it
like out of the turn like it was almost
like gonna be like a bad accident and
then he flipped I saw this happening
flipped off his City bike rolled into a
puddle and then got up he was like what
a way to start the day
and then he got onto his bike and he
just wiped himself off and he just got
on his bike and like just kept going and
I but I was like what a hilarious that's
so funny I mean kind of just calling up
what a way to start the day and I I was
like genuinely I kind of felt bad for
him but I was happy that he reacted that
way I was laughing out loud yeah yeah
was he did he look embarrassed no he
kind of looked just like he just goes
what a way to start the day that's
awesome and then God I think by the way
summer solstice is coming up Wednesday
June 21st did you know that the summer
solstice is the longest day and then it
starts to get shorter from there because
I always thought it stayed though I
always thought the longest day or like
it was light out in New York till like 9
30 in August but in August it's already
starting to get dark yeah I remember
when I used to think that but a while
back I realized oh the longest day
of the years so the longest day of the
year will be Wednesday June 21st it will
be light out till nine o'clock at night
it's probably past it probably dude you
know what time it gets light out now
because I've been like sometimes like
waking up at like five in the morning
full sun
finally gets up about 505 every morning
so the baby's up you can't
you can't slide that she's up she's and
at this age when you know she's reaching
the she's almost two they just you have
to they're up they're not and even if
you put the TV on they're up you have to
just get up with them so she goes you
can't make that at like 7 30. huh can't
make that like seven we tried more
manageable but but baby girl baby girl
wake up and she'll wake up she goes
diaper diaper and then she says that her
diaper is dirty but now she knows a
trick well she if she just says diapers
in Russian but it's pretty much usually
if you've seen this thing now where
parents will put like a I forget what
it's called but it's like a like a light
in the kids room and then like it has
color coding so like if it's red which
it does you can time it so you could say
the Delilah like all right if this is
red you don't get out of bed until turns
green okay did you ever hear that so
they had this thing on their bed and you
could time it and color code it so like
if you don't want to get out of bed
until seven you can say all right so
we're gonna do this thing if you wake up
and this is red try to stay in bed or go
back to see it when it turns green you
can get up and I I know so many people
who are using that right and uh I guess
it's like something that's like you know
a technique that works so
well I mean I guess what's gonna start
to happen is whatever this is what
happened with my other girl is they
start to then wake up at five or five in
the morning but then they just sit and
like hang out by themselves for a little
while and then they start to get you
know right now as soon as she wakes up
she's scared
it's because
um we have like uh scarecrows hanging
from her stealing with a noose around
the neck so she gets scared as soon as
she wins I bet she she thought she
wanted that at first and then yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah we have we have
skinned rabbits upside over her crib so
she gets as soon as she wakes up she
gets scared
2023 is the year of the water rabbit
what's a water ride
what a ill there's rabbits in the water
disgusting ugh I don't need that I'm
done with rabbits I've never eaten a
rabbit yeah I've never had a rabbit
hasenpfeffer is what it's called in
Germany is that what the rabbit is I've
never had a rabbit that's what they said
in Mighty Ducks they just they so
much you know what a rabbit my aunt had
a rabbit and it died her name was
Annabelle and I had to throw her out in
plastic bag I've told you that I don't
know if I don't know if you did I never
told you that no they built a little
crate for her my uncle built a little
crate and it would these little
pellets and it was like vicious this
thing but it was a full full Annabelle
and then it died one day and then my
aunt put it in like five plastic bags
from Stop and Shop and I had to throw it
out in the trash against the tree
what are you gonna do it was dead what
are we gonna do let me tell you I I
crashed at someone's house for a week
that had a rabbit they two four
seven three six five yep okay constantly
I mean if they walk from here to here
there's eight shits non-stop and
I'm not even joking it's kind of crazy
actually but uh I don't know about
rabbits yeah I don't need it I'm not
again I like animals I'm just not a pet
in the house guy not at least this point
in my life I guess because my kids are
too small I don't want want another
responsibility what's a What's it in a
rabbit and a bunny is a bunny a baby I
think a bunny is a baby rabbit is it I
think so so the Easter bunny is a baby
the Easter Bunny is clearly the Peter
what's his name Peter can't tell no
she's funny it's referred to rabbits
affectionately okay
oh bunnies are young and rabbits are
adults
well then the Easter Bunny I don't
understand then it's too young then too
young for me is the Easter bunny a boy
or a girl
or is that two different people
so who's Peter Cottontail female
wow the Easter Bunny is female look at
that then who Who the hell's Peter
Cottontail I think that's from a like a
children's book oh he's so he's just
just made up dude like he's not real
like he's the one now
um I don't uh yeah I uh I don't know um
for me and by the way for me Easter is
one of those holidays that I can I I it
doesn't it doesn't uh I don't need it
yeah
nothing against religion yeah but I used
to it my family was goes hard in the
paint with Easter everyone's getting in
their dresses and we used to go to
church and then we used to go out to eat
and by the way you go out to eat on
Easter and it's really just a it's
terrible it's a prefix menu everywhere
they rush you and they rush you out I
don't know it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's uh it's Amateur hour going out
going out for dinner on Valentine's Day
on Easter on Mother's Day yeah what are
you doing yeah no point we did a
Mother's Day picnic for this Mother's
Day two weeks ago and we had a great
time Delilah had strep throat but we had
a good time let me tell you about the
time I murdered the fish by accident
order if it's by accident
it's a manslaughter right I mans floated
myself you were talking about the rabbit
I uh I bought a new fish it was a
Japanese fighting fish you know those
you gotta leave in the bowl by
themselves if you put two in there they
do get out no you see these guys no they
like they like have like these weird
like Japanese fighting fish
you've seen it you've seen it if you
can't put two in the same one they'll
fight to the death really yes or
immediately
uh yeah and one will get killed yeah
like yeah one will die they will they
will fight to the death and then one
will die
so you can't put them in you they have
to be alone they could go with other
fish they can't go with one of their own
they will fight to the death so I get
this Japanese fighting fish and I get a
fish I had my fish tank and I had I
bought like the rocks and like you know
like the little guy and they had like
the scuba diver with the bubbles coming
out of the treasure and everything and I
bought like this like Coral thing that
has like a cave and I went to change I
got the fish and I went to put together
the the fish tank I did I did the rocket
I I put in the right pH and all that
stuff and I
and I put everything together and I got
the the the actual filter going and then
I finished and I was like so proud of
myself and I'm like where the is
the fish right the fish was not in that
what happened well I lifted up that cave
that I bought and I had crushed him
under the cave in the Rocks as I set up
the tank yeah so I got the fish and
literally stomped it immediately
immediately
I
here here's my question with the
Japanese fighting fish how do they mate
and have sex if they always want to kill
each other maybe it's different maybe
you can't believe maybe maybe I I'm not
that educated but I always I killed a
lot of fish in my day because when we
were little they would give you fish
like it was no big deal like there was a
pet store around the corner from my
aunt's house yeah and you'd go and they
called them the feeder fish yeah you
know these goldfish and back then they
charged you I think I think five or ten
cents for a fish can you imagine buying
a life yeah for five to ten cents and by
the way they call them feeder fish
because they would feed them the bigger
fish but if you kept that fish it's
gross a regular fish remember five I
kept one for six years number five cents
we could buy individual bazooka gums
that had the comics on them I missed
Bazooka gum yeah yeah loose loose coming
goodbye loose Bazooka gum all you can't
buy it anymore
I used to go to I used to have a candy
shop my neighborhood they used to sell
them loose I'll take you to the candy
shop I'll turn into the lollipop I got
them life to go back to that right we
weren't saying that I wonder were people
in the 90s were our parents in the 90s
saying I want life to go back to the way
it was in the 70s I think it's just
always yeah we left our front doors open
everybody in the neighborhood knew each
other yeah you know speaking of that I
wanted we smoked cigarettes that weren't
bad for you back then I wanted to wait
um
I wanted to wait a little bit and tell
you guys because you know I you know how
I'm open about things but not like all
the time you know I'm open I'm open
about things yeah but I feel like
there's been there's been things that
have been going on
with me
um that I wasn't even as comfortable and
open of a book as I am I was like I
don't want to share this because it's
struggling with it and it's been hard
for me and I wanted to just wait you
know because I went to the doctor
um a couple of weeks ago and it's been
difficult for me to deal with but I I
went
to the doctor I I went
I went to the doctor and and I was
struggling because I was like not
feeling like a hundred percent I just
was feeling off
and I went I went
to the doctor two weeks ago and I got
like a bunch of tests and they were like
this could be off that could be off and
and then finally though they came to me
and they I had to do because remember I
couldn't make hey babe out of nowhere a
couple of weeks ago is because I had to
get this test done uh and they looked in
me
and they came up with
a diagnosis for me that I'll be okay you
know that's why I've been doing even
like the stoics and all that stuff like
kind of just getting
in touch with what fate and life could
be because you know
they said they've like you know looking
at your results Chris and we're just you
know we don't want you to be scared but
they said you've been diagnosed with
this has been hey babe
[Laughter]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe